no no no because i'm trying to see i'm
this is we're lying we are officially
live okay we're live episode number 71
david yes
yes sir 71 with adam sauce and barry
he'll be barry this is your first time
here
this is my maiden voyage yes yes by the
way if you don't know barry berry is a
three-time crystal ball winner with
zillow
and a former lead producer of rock of
ages the movie rock of ages which i've
spoken about on the podcast multiple
times
with tom cruise there was a broadway
show which you let but you were also in
the movie
i was the wrestler so tell us the whole
story tell us your background a little
bit
so um from my experiences on cnbc i was
on cnbc for a long long time
and uh someone someone liked
i guess either my look or my voice and
said hey would you like to be a movie
i'm like yeah i would love to be in a
movie so
i had no clue that it was going to be
dressed up in this pastel outfit as
colonel kaboom in this kids movie right
so
but i networked and you know that's how
things happen and wound up being in a
few other movies i want to be in nine
movies and
one of the movies i was in is a great
movie it's called barry monday
i uh i actually play the uh i play the
doctor
and i made the trailer in the movie
barry monday it's a really good movie
and so the guy who directed it and wrote
is chris lorenzo
so he became friendly showed me the
script to rock of ages four other guys
and myself we took a shot took it off
broadway people went nuts for it
we said let's really get stupid and put
it on broadway and good thing i was
ignorant about how risky it is but we
did and it was a big success what was
bigger but
the movie or broadway so the movie i
wasn't really crazy about
um you were in it well maybe that's the
reason but now that
let's get let's get some imdb up here
okay let's get on this so i i wasn't
crazy about the movie because it made a
lot of changes the theatrical experience
was
absolutely incredible so we we went we
were 27 longest running show on broadway
we stopped and then what happened was we
we wound up uh going back
on off broadway because a little easier
no unions easier overhead
and uh been covered hit so we've been
shut down since then
oh so you were doing it all the way up
until covid yeah yeah the broadway show
some of the movies i was in yeah yeah
what should we look at here barry you
know what i i really i really like barry
monday you know it's listen this is not
it's like i'm very monday i'm trying to
see which movie though oh
everybody they'll put the trailer on for
about this week we cannot because it's
it'll uh it'll flag us so barry monday
the bearing then wakes up one morning
attack to realize that he's missing his
family jewels
to make sure you make him i'm the doctor
i'm the doctor who removed him
he learns he's facing a paternity uh
lawsuit filed by a woman he can't
remember having sex with i mean it's a
very uh based on a true story
yeah right it must be yeah it must be
okay so
how does that go with real estate how do
you go into
becoming the real estate expert so you
know it's interesting because if you
have a lot of different business
interests that are different
like with anything else there are
certain things that hold true regardless
of the industry you just got to learn
the industry
if you meet somebody and they speak six
different languages like wow they're
really smart
but when it comes to different vocations
people say well no you can only
pigeonhole you in one
you don't have to you can have very many
different
uh business expertise um over time
now you run businesses though i mean
because the way we got introduced to
each other i get a call from greg share
yes
greg says there's a guy that wants to
talk to you he says look up this guy
i look him up because he apparently had
investors or some business dealings he
had with you thinks highly of you
then uh uh you and i get on the phone
together then we had a meeting together
louis bossie
with a woman that showed up with us
where your three-year-old son flirted
with
my three-year-old grandson
three-year-old grandson you're a
grandpappy
um i'm a two-time grandpappy my daughter
nicole just had
baby karina named after my mother uh a
couple just a couple of days ago
a couple days ago so uh you said this is
your second my second grandchild yeah
yes yes well you know uh his last name
is habib you know habibi you know how
you know what habibi means i'm sure you
get this all the time do you know what
that means
my dear my dear my dear my lord love
your friends
love that song every saturday night i'm
out in the club
meeting armenian girls adam meeting
armenian girls
actually not far out our goal today is
to get
smarter when it comes down to real
estate today should i buy a house today
should i refinance
does janet yellen know what she's
talking about is she the expert
is powell the experts who's controlling
the bubble who's influencing the bubble
you know maybe i ought to wait for
interest rates to come down because i
heard rates went up a little bit you
know maybe i should wait
six more months maybe things are going
to go
all of these things we're going to
figure some of those things out he's
going to reveal it throughout the day
we're going to we're going to see what
barry has to teach us about that we've
got a lot of different topics to get
into a ton of different topics again
by the way how does somebody get a
crystal ball award with zillow how does
that happen most accurate real estate
for
they get 150 of the top economists and i
guess i
somehow fell into that category and uh
you each give your forecasts and your
predictions
and as it turns out three times that was
the most accurate
wow and also in the top 10 the last five
years but
uh 17 19 and 20 was the most accurate 17
19 and 20. how do they judge actually
that's a good question how do you give
you a forecast and whatever the actual
appreciation levels were based upon your
you know who's closest to getting the
correct appreciation from it
i'm a national average from national
where it's national and what's your
formula how do you come about
you know so my son dan really helps out
a lot he's my right hand person and so
we we look at this together but i really
have a lot of credit to the people that
so i'm blessed to be a professional
speaker so i go out and i meet with
my audiences typically real estate
agents and mortgage professionals all
around the country
and you get feedback from them and so i
learn and get a lot of feedback
before when data comes out it's old
already by the time you see it right
but if you talk to somebody you meet
them and you press the flash they're
telling you what's going on right now
so we were able to see trends and
develop algorithms based upon that
foreign one is going out there and
shaking hands and you're hearing what
people are saying
who are selling out there they're
meeting with clients on a daily basis
and by the time you get the
article that's written it's already too
late because somebody knew about it 24
hours before they wrote it so having
said not only that but the data is
old because a lot of times it's based on
closings which means this is market
conditions three months
data we read in an article it's already
too old got it okay well let's let's see
what you got to say about some of these
things here that's going on if you've
got any uh
lottery predictions of some numbers
since you've got the crystal ball on
your side
we'd all love to know i highly doubt
we're gonna know that
anytime so folks if you're watching this
you got questions about real estate post
your questions
on twitter pbd podcast go on twitter
post your questions with hashtag pbd
podcast regarding real estate and we'll
see what barry has to do with that guy
track the questions going on twitter and
we'll come to some of you guys regarding
your questions but prior to going into
the real estate questions
your favorite topic is what peter theo
recently did okay so let's go to page
three peter
before before we get started i feel like
we should make an announcement
i mean we're gonna get right into
business i get it but you had a pretty
big damn weekend i mean
i had a baby over what just happened pat
i had a brooklyn
ivy bed david that arrived well jen had
the baby
on on uh she did and she by the way
shout out to jen man here's the thing
so june 26th is our anniversary it's 12
years we've been married wow
at 5 39 in the morning uh
brooklyn is born on on the anniversary
yes
and uh uh so we go into the hospital
eight o'clock at night she goes into
labor boom 5 39 in the morning obviously
the last thing you want is labor to go
from midnight one o'clock two o'clock
because you're all
not going on you know you have no sleep
and you go into it
and then baby comes and you got to go to
a few more hours and then finally she
gets some rest couple hours after having
a baby
jen gets up and walks around she's going
to the bathroom coming back just an
absolute trooper
fourth baby that she had natural no
pitocin no epidural nothing
none of it not a single thing that's not
same yeah that's absolutely insane she
took
nothing four she's a g she's a she's a g
at the highest level and then 35 hours
later she came home
yeah and it was so cool bringing uh the
baby home she
i put the uh brooklyn in the car and
dylan
tico seeing the kid reacting it was so
cool to see each of their reactions
tico's reaction was very interesting
when you looked at his eyes dylan was
ecstatic yes
cena wanted to play with her you know
and miss mommy so much but it was a
great
pop on the back seat was like done this
before cloud9 but here's the thing that
we talked about i said you know babe
moving forward
wherever we go to dinner we got to take
two cars because it's officially party
of eight
minimum it's the four kids it's me jen
melva and papa that's eight going to
dinner we have a problem
table for eight everywhere we go it's a
minimum if you join us it's nine if
mario joins us
ten if you don't elaborate you're gonna
be there i'll argue it's gonna
be there but but it's a minimum of table
of eight but we're excited we're excited
to have four kids here now
and uh if if we had it our way we had it
my way
you know if we were 10 years younger
we'd have 10 more kids but you know
we're limited at four right
i remember when you had three and you
were guys were kind of talking about a
fourth and jen was like i don't know
about it
believe it or not the idea of wanting to
have a fourth
was brought up by jen really jen
eventually
mine was five then we settled on three
okay we didn't talk about it and jen a
year ago brought it up saying babe i
think i want to have four
i said why she says i want santa to have
a baby sister so
the big god listen to the prayer and we
have a baby sister for santa there you
go so santa has somebody to play with
now so i know
i know we don't want to obviously spend
too much time on this but
what a whirlwind last six months you've
had i mean can we touch on that for a
second
uh you're living in dallas yeah you say
all right we're moving to
south florida last minute a month like
literally how much time did we tell you
guys that we're moving to florida i
don't know like 48 hours at a time
what was it when we said we're moving
like how much time did you actually have
i mean from the time i was told that we
were moving
i was back in norway i think that was a
month and eight days until i was on the
way to
florida there you go four weeks and we
gave that additional week hovering like
you're just kind of
making a little bit easier so you get to
south florida jen's pregnant
you're moving yeah and you rent that
house you rent it it's not
forget 40 people have coveted let's not
forget
yeah let's not forget that everybody
everything in a move to the office was
made by
mario and mickey and you and i don't
know who it was eric couple people were
helping out yes
they moved here and then long story
short you know we uh rented a house then
eventually we
bought a new house and then we're now
looking at a couple buildings we looked
at four buildings this week at fort
lauderdale a few nice buildings that
we're going to be making an offer on
and then meanwhile we've hired four new
c-suite executives with
insurance side php we've got we're up to
now 35 employees here full-time with
valuetainment so we got we got a lot of
stuff going on it's been great there's
people walking around that i have no
i don't even know where they i don't
know they are that's the idea of growing
a company though that's what i love
about it so you got two companies that
are growing and we got a lot of good
things going on so and
but but even at the same time right now
uh
i probably have i've never had a time in
my life where we have this many big
projects pending at the same time
ever we have the vault conference coming
up which we're about to announce two new
speakers one of the speakers we just got
this the guy we've been trying to get
for the last three years
the guy has nothing to do with business
but he has everything to do with
business
everything to do with business i can't
wait to he's a goat he's the greatest of
all time
in his space we'll announce that the
admiral is that yeah i can't tell you
who he is but we'll announce it next
week we have another person that's
coming that's going to have to do with
data analytics
the best in this world when it comes
down to data analytics both of those
guys will be at our event at the vault
i don't have the typical lineup of
speakers that people have at their
events i don't go after social media
influencers
i like data people i like business
people to be at the event we're gonna
vault's gonna be
absolutely out of this world type of an
event september first september diplomat
we're gonna have a yacht event
afterwards a party maybe even an after
party at the house possibly for like 50
people we'll do a low key type of a
party at the house
and then we got things going on finally
i worked on a
fiction book for five years and
eventually i just set it aside it's 107
000 words that's eventual that's
now coming to life and we're putting
some uh we we
we're making some big moves with this
book when it comes out i can't wait
people are going to read the book
they're going to think i'm absolutely
crazy what's on my mind
but it is what it is i've been holding
off on going up going live with this
book for a while i think it's time
we got a lot of projects going on so
anyways long story short lots moving
right now
two the biggest announcement will be
made at the vault at the end of the
vault which people are gonna have to
they'll see
what project we got going on i'm going
to fort worth tomorrow
for a shotgun flight one day flight that
i'm going and coming back i'm meeting
with some of the most powerful
investment bankers in fort worth for the
entire day it's going to be big in
fort worth like oil county and then
coming back so we got we got big things
cooking big things so you don't really
have much going on right now things are
pretty chilling bbd's live
no big deal that's a boring
life you know you know it that's a
boring life to play
small nothing nothing about what we got
and by the way
here's one thing like somebody asked me
a question the other day they said pat
what is the driver what is the biggest
driver people don't realize what they're
driving we talk about making history and
all that other stuff
i'll tell you today what the biggest
driver is like what my biggest concern
today is
we escaped iran because in iran we
didn't have any voice you couldn't say
anything you have to
like imagine being quiet your entire
life because you're afraid if you god
forbid you tell anybody what your faith
is you're going to jail
god forbid you tell anybody what your
religion is your parents are going to
get a god
so you have to be just be silenced your
entire life i cannot stand
being silenced with opinions and
thoughts that we have i can't stand it
so the next phase next 20 years is to be
able to give a platform to those who
have been silenced
in a complete different way whether you
have some opinions respectful opinions
you have some thoughts you have some
ideas there's a little bit controversy
to it
fine come and tell us what your thoughts
are let's have some good debate
let's hash it out let's let the audience
decide for themselves so
my biggest motivation next 20 years is
going to be to make sure we give voice
to the people i've been silenced a
little bit
and i want to have some entertainment i
want to laugh i want to make a lot of
unique projects together so that that's
the next one
there's a lot of silencing going on
right now i'm not a fan of that i'm
cancelled culture
it's terrible we just had an episode we
did a podcast last week our short clip
channel got suspended because i told a
tweet that cole beasley had we brought
it up the channel got a strike and it
was suspended for a week
the valuetainment short clips i just
think there's too much of that going on
right now where people are worried about
different
opinions listen just let people hear the
opinions and make up your mind for
yourself you know
i'm a guy that's read atlas shrug and
i'm a guy that's with communist
manifesto
you read those books something's going
to make sense to you on both sides and
you're going to say you know what i
understand what carl was talking about
because he was upset because what
happened with them
and here's the guy let me go find out
what he's all about i understand what
ayn rand is talking about
i relate to this i get it my argument
got stronger but to say
you can only read one side and you can
only do this
that's a little bit of thinking you
already have all the answers and
and i'm not about that i want my kids to
read books and have an opinion for
themselves through debate so we're going
to do our part
and uh i have a feeling the man upstairs
is going to be with us because he's been
with us for a while as long as the
vision's real you're going to be all
right our vision is very real
it's very sincere the right people are
showing up and we're not slowing down
god keeps us healthy the next 20 40
years are going to be epic you're going
to read about it you're going to write
about it you're going to watch movies
about it crystal clear
it's not arrogance it's pure confidence
and it's just becoming a reality so
that's that part
can we get into the podcast because i
want to learn from this moment i do too
but i mean
i think that was great what you just did
for the last few years
yeah i i think i think it's necessary so
weird the word to me today is
necessary it's not even about the houses
it's not about i drive a truck today
like i don't know if people realize i
drive a damn truck i drive a ford
truck pickup truck well it's a nice one
it is a truck though it's a truck
you know i've had the the nice cars and
i love all the nice cars i live in a
nice place i have a good life but the
next phase is purely going
to a bit of a fight that we're going to
have we're going to have the fun part
but the vision is going to become a
reality
i'm very confident about it very very
confident about it so we'll see what's
going to happen with that again
a media game you're dealing with heavy
weights and to deal with heavy weights
you have to be
able to face them off and have fun with
them and build a relationship with them
and i think we're going to be able to
pull that off we'll see
we'll see if we have the goodies the
next 20 years is going to tell us if we
have the goodies or not
we will find out the next 20 years okay
real estate before we get into real
estate i want to go into the peter
thiel's story with you okay
so peter thiel billionaire libertarian
a guy who was one of the first investors
on facebook he put a half a million
dollars on facebook
he has amassed a 5 billion
dollar fortune in tax-free roth ira
count now if you don't know how roth
iras work different than the ira
you put money into an ira it's pre-tax
money you get a write-off every year but
at the end of it say you're
you're putting 4 500 every year into an
ira 30 years later you got half a
million dollars you take that half a
million dollars out
you will pay taxes on the half a million
dollars the roth ira you put money
after taxes into the roth and then
eventually you're making
tax-free money you decide to take the
money out after 59 and a half
great you don't pay any taxes so how has
he raised
and increases account to 5 billion
that's the question this is a business
insider story paypal co-founder peter
thiel
has managed to grow a tax free
retirement account worth less
less than 2 000.99 to 5 billion
today according to a report from pro
publica the roth ira was created by
congress in 1997 as a way to
for middle class americans he's
definitely not middle class too safe for
retirement dependent
of their employer retirement account
initially had two thousand dollars per
year contribution limit today the
contribution limit is six thousand
dollars americans
that make more than 140 000 per year are
unable to contribute to the account
that's because the tax treatment of a
roth ira is so beneficial to its user
that it allows
after-tax money to compound for decades
in the stock market and then be
withdrawn tax free as long as the owner
is 59 and a half years old
field grew his fortune by using his roth
ira account to invest in early state
startups
which translated to massive windfalls
when those successful companies went
public
years later from there thiel was able to
use that windfall to invest in more
early stage companies
within his roth ira account now worth 5
billion
thoughts sherry go ahead a similar story
on one of the other paypal founders did
the same thing
and i think that that's why you're
hearing for a lot of calls for
we should limit the benefit right now if
the numbers are out there like two
million dollars should be the limit
threshold of what you can
benefit and the other aspect of this
that's really interesting is
you get the step up basis when you pass
it on to your heirs which is another
thing that they're trying to poke they
want the
benefit to stop at death it's just a
difficult thing to do because
you know peter thiel was in a position
where he had the ability to invest in
real early startups do it through the
roth ira and then the explosive growth
over
i think he started this you know over 20
years ago that explosive growth over
time
you know that's how you reach these
enormous numbers so
you know i watch cnbc all the time and
this is like the number one story on
cnbc right now like how the hell
did this happen so if you're not
familiar with the roth ira i'm a huge
fan of it
right so what i tell people is if you're
going to start investing start investing
long-term buy and hold if you work for a
company especially
a company that has a match with a 401k
that's a great option
free money it's a match ira that's
another option
but if you want to kind of do something
outside your company or if you're an
independent contractor
or if you don't if your company doesn't
have a match or 401k a roth ira
is an amazing option i've been telling
our friend eric galera to get a roth ira
for about a year now
and he's like yeah maybe next week all
right anyway get started that's the best
way you don't say the best eric listen
to this listen to the guy
adam here so you know they said the best
day to plant the tree is 20 years ago
the next best day is today so
roth ira i started a roth ira in 2008
right after the great
recession i had no clue about investing
i had no clue about a 401k i can barely
spell 401k
i remember i started taking my company
match well you know how to spell pen 15
though i do
i do i just learned today what pen 15
meant i didn't know what until you and
david taught me today
okay go ahead keep going so i started a
roth ira and i started a 401 can i
started investing that
that way now here's the catch the roth
ira is so good
that they only allow certain people to
um contribute right so i remember when i
was first starting i wasn't making 120
grand whatever the number was
140 it was amazing so it was 140 grand
now i'm making a little bit more than
that
so i can't contribute so i haven't been
able to contribute in whatever it's been
almost 10 years now
but for anyone out there making less 140
grand if you don't have a 401k get your
ass involved with the roth ira
the flip side of that would get back to
peter thiel here is this is insane
you're talking about how they're maybe
capping what a roth ira could
possibly be a couple million bucks
when i read this i thought he had five
million in there and i was like oh damn
yeah how do you do that
it's five million five million it can't
be five billion five billion
in a roth ira and when you have a
contribution limit of apparently two
thousand dollars when this started in
now the contribution limit is six grand
you're telling me he's somehow
he's put in he's maxed out his roth ira
and built it up for
five billion dollars there's clearly
some tax loophole going on here
yeah like i get it there's one side of
the coin you can do whatever you want
you know and that's how you want
you know what for me you know what you
know how i would use it here's how i
would use it
i remember one time you know uh you know
guys would go
talking about this kid in our school was
like hey this guy took uh ten thousand
dollars of his dad's money and he turned
into 160 000
buying all stocks i was in 10th grade
right and i was like oh my gosh whatever
you know i wish my dad would give me ten
thousand he's probably a crook he's
probably this he's probably that
everybody trashed this guy right years
later
i ran into him three years ago okay this
guy i don't know this kid like we're not
friends but i ran into him
three years ago i think he's in merchant
service today like five years ago
i said are you are you the guy i think
you are he says yes
i said weren't you the kid that your dad
gave you 10 grand and you had like 160
thousand dollars he says
how do you remember that was 27 years
ago i remember it because i'm like
i'd love to have 160 000 here's what's
crazy
that story fired me up like [ __ ] i'd
love to have 160 000
versus some people are like look at this
guy all he cares about is money
look this is how i would use this if i
was biden today if i
really cared about people saving their
money i would say look here's how big of
an
upside a roth ira can have for you as
well he didn't do anything different
all he did is the investments he made
within the ira were into stocks you
could do it as well
it was within startups you can do this
well it was within ipos you can do many
of those as well
just get better and learn about how
money works but definitely start a roth
ira
i would drive the hell out of it and use
it as a way to motivate other people to
start a 200
a month roth ira patrick if you think
about it right at nine percent money is
going
which nine point nine percent is the
average of the s p for the last 50 years
at that level money's going to double
roughly every seven years so
you know the doubling or compound it's
real like it's the eighth wonder of the
world it's really
magic when you think about compounding
so the question that i would ask people
is would you rather have a hundred
thousand dollars or a penny that doubles
every day for a month
and at the end of a month it's 5.3
million dollars
unless there's 31 days of the month it's
10.7 million dollars so the key is
it's the last double the earlier you
start the more you can get if money's
going to double every seven years how
many doubles can you get out of that
i say congratulations peter thiel more
power too buddy i hope that 5 billion
turns into 50 billion
and i hope more people go start doing
roth iras as well if they can
let me tell you this isn't the last
we're hearing of this story the tax man
come if they're going to figure out
something of course they will
they're going to figure out somewhere
listen 5 million congratulations 5
billion
you got some explaining nobody but no no
he has no explaining to do
no no no no this you see that's the
mindset of the majority in america it's
a problem adam
the government has explaining to do not
him he has
no way he didn't break any laws the
government created this loophole
he didn't do it he simply went and
followed the rules and the guidelines
that his accountant gave him and he's
got 5 billion
so the government has a lot of
explaining to do not peter thiel
unfortunately the media is bashing him
he didn't do nothing wrong
they're going to find some ways to come
out as an example unfortunately
it's a shame if they do that because the
government's back in 1999 and this is
the guy that started one of the
the the paypal mafia founders and he
also started what palantir he was
initial
yeah investor in facebook he's uh he's
in early on
a monster now here correct me if i'm
wrong i don't know if you guys heard
this barry and pat
he got 1.7 million shares of paypal
at .001 cents okay
1.7 million shares at less than a tenth
of a penny
now if you can do that too person out
there starting a roth ira
you can potentially have a billion bucks
a good report good for no one else has
that access good
no it's not about no one else has that
access why don't you go network amongst
the right people go shake some hands and
meet those guys
now go network at the founders of paypal
stop bro
stop what are you talking about yeah go
network with those guys
forget about him okay he went and hung
out with the paypal mafia which all
those guys came out being billionaires
right you know what i'm talking about
there's a bunch of one of them there's a
bunch of it's like 40 names that we're
talking
about read uh read huffman but but
here's here's what you could i spoke at
texas a m university i don't know seven
years ago sixty six years ago sometime i
remember that talk yeah when i went to
school you don't do drugs you get high
off life
i get high off life i don't like drugs i
remember thinking i remember coffee
coffee freaks me out i remember i think
being high when i was watching that i
was like
holy [ __ ] this is what i'm doing wrong
texas you know what i told him here's
what i told him i said forget about
meeting a peter thiel
go meet the peter thiel of your
university if i'm school there's a
different camps group of camps that you
want to be you want to get close to
someone i get with the camps that are
partying and have all access to all the
best drugs and the women that's the camp
they want to be a part of
some go to the camps that are you know
playing video games that's a different
camp that you go to
some go to the camps that are you know
just be smoking weed and just getting
high and they're just doing whatever
they're doing some are the fraternities
some of the sports guys some of the and
but if there's a group of people
that are the idea guys that are saying
how about we go take over the world if
we would have come out with this
go in that camp yeah and then see what
happens 10 years later guess what
more power to peter thiel and those guys
that got into that camp
elan by the way it was 58 birthday
yesterday he turned 50 yesterday 50
50 years old yesterday i think he's
going to be i think he's going to do
something with his life
i think he's starting to think resume
for the first 50 years i think he owns
the best resume i think he's got the
best resume
for the first female other than barry's
by the time he was 50. he had three
crystal balls already right there
so movies broadway yeah and a lot of
other things but but let's go let's go
into
by the way speaking of peter thiel and
this roth ira have you ever read the
book the power of zero
yes what a book what a great book what a
book that was actually a book that
changed my mind
yeah which part which part of it of the
book tell me the whole book i mean it's
a it's a thin little book says this ipad
yeah
uh i think ricky and i my good friend
ricky aguilar and i were talking about
the other day
but my story with this real quick is i
remember being in vegas i was doing the
the nalbatore whatever
and uh they had this guest speaker i
could not tell you his name for the life
of me but i don't know
kai if you pull up the power of zero you
can david mcknight david mcknight there
he is i think he's from utah
and he talked about the power of zero
and the zero is this tax-free retirement
and he talked about how taxes are sure
to go up and
how the government budget is you know
completely
overloaded on social security and
medicare and medicaid and
if you want to have a tax for retirement
a big staple of that is a roth ira
and also the what is it the lerp life
insurance retirement plan yep
but basically he broke down how you can
have a zero
a zero percent tax retirement and that
changed my life and i remember being in
the back of a room
i don't know why they do conferences in
vegas because i was sure as hell hung
over
and i remember like popping my head up
being like what huh your time
and it just changed my life in the power
of zero and that's uh a great example of
what you can do with the roth ira
when did you start investing by the way
i was relatively young i was
uh i was actually about 22 years old
when i started investing young started
yeah 23 when i started investing in real
estate
how how old 23 in real estate 22 in the
stock market what's the first thing you
ever bought real estate
um i bought the condo that i lived in
for sixty eight thousand dollars
wondering how i was ever going to do it
i bought in jersey i moved from brooklyn
to new jersey it was
way over my head i stretched and
stretched and stretched
but uh i i would so when i was a kid i
used to sell stereo equipment out of
this trunk of my car right
so i got a chance to go all over to
different areas and i said wow
i would ask questions i was always
curious i said why are values here in
new jersey so much cheaper than they are
equidistant from new york in the
opposite direction so i said maybe i
should buy something there so i bought
this little condo there and two years
later it more than doubled in value
and by the time i was 25 i had invested
in like 20 different properties because
i thought that that was the way to go
barry that same place you bought at 68
000 what is it worth today
if i were to guess i'd probably say
probably 400 500 400 500 000
wow 60 to 4 500 000 so long term play
with real estate if you buy and hold
you're going to be all right population
is going up so you know it's
and it's tough to build we could talk
about how tough it is to build right now
how tough it is to build right now
because you cannot find the guys that
are actually doing the work for you yeah
well you know labor is tough uh that's a
big that's a big one that people don't
really think about you know there's
problems with that that we can get into
with the
with the pandemic unemployment
assistance 9.3 million jobs available we
can't film i mean really
if you incent people to stay home
they're going to stay home there's a
portion of the population that have to
worry about child care so of course
but there's a lot of people that hey
look you can't blame them if i'm going
to make more money if i want to make 18
an hour to stay home i'll make less than
that to work and work
has other expenses and is tough it's
gonna be hard but a lot of soft costs
land's expensive when you think about it
if you construct and the cost of your
construction
is let's just say it's 150 bucks a
square foot you want to build a 2
000 square foot home you're already at
300 000.
land soft costs you're at 500 000
and you haven't made any profit and
people are wondering why is there no
inventory
for the demand of first-time home buyers
it's because we can't supply the new
inventory
people are not able to to buy a home
below a half a million dollars very
easily or find a home below a half a
million dollars very easily especially
like new jersey yeah
new york in many places of the country
though it has gotten pretty pricey
on new construction so you have to find
an older home an existing home
but those aren't coming up on the market
because somebody has to sell that which
means they now have to buy a much more
expensive home correct in a tight
inventory environment yeah then the
price
they just came out with the average
price of home officially is at 350 000
this is as of uh i think this article we
talked about last week kai
350 is average price of home today so i
want to talk about that because it's not
the average actually it's the median
price and there's a big difference there
and the media oftentimes messes this up
because what they'll say is that's an
increase of almost 25
year-over-year so they're saying real
estate's it's going to bubble because
it's up 25 that's not the case median
means that half the sales above at half
the sales below it no inventory on the
lower end it's down 35
in sales because there's no inventory
homes over a million are up more than
200 percent
over a hundred over 750 180 percent
increase
in how long and what time in the last
year okay so the median home price has
been skewed
much higher based upon the mix of sales
i got it actual appreciation
is 13 now we just got new numbers today
which i'm not privy to as of yet
but year over year it's about 13 it's
still hotter than we'd like okay but
it's not 25. so 13
means a 300 000 house last year's 339
right now
it's it's exactly right yes correct yeah
i mean he's got a calculator yeah so so
you guys so okay so
so if we're looking at that being the
price so is today
a good time the whole thing let's stay
on what you just talked about which is
hard to kind of get the builders
who's taking the biggest hit right now
because when i talk to gas with gcs
and i say house business gc general
contracts how's business oh man we
we're like we can't even we have you
guys keep six months 12 months like we
got calm people want our business right
now
who's winning right now who's losing
right now because of what's going on
with real estate well if you look at
some of the earnings from builders
they're skyrocketing right lanark just
came out with earnings of skyrocketing
so they're certainly
in a very strong position even though
costs are higher
they put in the contracts escalation
clauses and things like that that can
protect them
so people are buying homes for x amount
on the contract wind up paying more by
the time they go to closing
so i don't know if it's a win because
you could also say somebody who
purchased a home a year ago they won too
right so and i think if you buy a home
today and if you don't do it
unwisely you will continue to be a
winner because i see real estate values
continuing to go higher
unwisely so people talk about a housing
bubble there is no housing bubble but
you could put yourself in a housing
bubble
if there's a home that's valued today
that the real value if you would get an
appraisal or an automated valuation
model and it's four hundred thousand the
seller is going for the moon they're
gonna put it up there for
450. and if you get emotional in your
transaction and you start competing
against a couple of people
and you pay 525 for a home that's worth
you put yourself in your own housing
bubble there's not a housing bubble but
you just bought
unwisely what's the alternative though
there's nothing in the market listen
it's not easy you have to be patient
sometimes you may have to move a little
bit further from a specific geographic
area
that's tough to do from thai to job i've
been there for 12 years you're 100 right
i am not saying it's easy
i'm saying that there are certainly many
challenges here but
you have to be able to so we created
this tool by the way patrick we created
a tool that will tell you
at what point in the future the home
that you are purchasing above what it's
purchased so yeah that 400 000
valued home that you purchased let's say
for 460 okay which is pretty heavy above
asking price when in the future will
that home be worth 460 is it
eight months is it 24 months is it third
or is it eight years
if it's eight years maybe you should
think but there's certain markets you
will catch up within a year or two you
might say
okay i might be into that got it so i
guess the question like right now we
have a question here mark
shock who asks the question on twitter
he said my wife and i have down payments
saved and ready to buy we live in the
dfw metroplex and homes are selling 30
to 100 000
over asking price at times all cash and
no inspection
should we buy now or wait a year or two
will the market get better
better is relative terms so will it get
more expensive yeah it'll get more
expensive so
should you bite the bullet yeah you have
to just you have to really every home
is different there is no blanket result
because you cannot duplicate a home only
one homecoming
can you pull up his tweet out there so
we can see what he keeps going so what
you want to try and do is
get the best advice that you can as to
what if i pay over
how long will it take me to catch up and
of the choices that are out there and
there may not be very many choices
but try to make the best decisions
possible be patient over the next 30 60
90 days because
you'll be okay there but two years from
now that value is going to be up
significantly
kai can you go to go to zillow.com
matter of fact just go to zillow.com
and go to uh uh uh i'd be i'd love to
know what mark's zip code is go to dfw
uh we could pull it up on our site we'd
have to get in go to dfw
just with dallas fort worth okay this is
a site that everybody has access to so
just kind of take a look at this
foray for sale for sale and
go uh where's the range you run at the
top go close that x go to
price go to price and go from uh
300 now put 300 min to 500 000
okay to 500 000 yeah right there let's
take a look at what comes up
and then uh uh get the list uh that the
list comes out you literally put three
hundred dollars
so maybe change it to three hundred
thousand i don't know what kind of house
there you go
press done there you go okay all right
so then go on that 450 right there for
you that says 450 click on that
so this 450 thousand dollar house
beautiful one bedroom
two bath is just a gorgeous house think
about that now go a little lower
it's been on the market for 263 days
okay click on that
click on the house you were on and just
go lower go lower on the right side
right there keep going lower lower lower
level grab that mls number for a second
uh go one four four like a true crystal
ball champion yeah one four four four
all right i'm telling um i know that
i've got people watching this so i
i got my my boyfriend's office get that
get that mls number it's one
four four four nine five six five and if
you're listening put that in our our
system and let's see how long it'll take
for this home to get up there and what
it's worth today
keep going up keep going up so zillow
keep keep going up
a little bit higher keep going keep
going kai okay this was bill check this
out
this was built in 1946 i don't even know
what house this is for 450 it's one
bedroom
two bathroom for 450 that's got to be
the land because now you don't
understand this is not even in a great
area like this is
this is keep going down don't be talking
trash about texas buddy
no i got a greater addison yes kai keep
going lower okay here we go
so 2020 price price change 8.95 hey
what 9.95 listed for sale
taxes on the property were paid tax
assessment look at that it was paid on
176 180 so it's gone down over the years
the tax assessment on it keep going
lower
keep going lower i mean at 450 i'm
looking at a house like this
this has got to be like a five acre
property with a mini house on type in
dallas just get back don't even do dfw
just go to dallas
you know just do dallas and
here pull out that well pull up the one
for 4.99 right there
because that's a single player either
one of those it's four bedrooms let's
take
one four six zero five five two one go
lower go lower
just go all the way down kai keep going
and to see the numbers what it looks
like
lower chi okay right there 491 just went
into the market
uh no tax history available you're
looking at 4.99 so this house
assuming this house uh does it show what
year was built
it looks like a new build looks like a
new built house i mean you got to know
like right now if you're in the market
you're middle america
newly built 2021 222 per square feet
okay
thank god it's got ac by the way because
you're going to need it in texas in
dallas
you're sitting there at a 4 out of 499
house
okay middle income family how much down
payment am i going to need for that 5
percent or can i do a hundred percent
financing you can do
today 95 97 financing okay let's just
say 95
financing five percent on 500 is 25 000.
25 000
down which may not seem like a lot of
money it's a lot of money for people
that are making 70 grand a year
not a lot of people have 25 thousand
dollars down payment just put up there
okay so you put 25 000 down your payment
on that's going to be what what's your
payment going to be on that give or take
is it fair to say your payment on a 500
000 bucks
2500 a month you're doing it at five
times i see what you're doing
so twenty five hundred dollars a month
which is not bad and you gotta put
twenty five thousand dollars down
estimate a monthly payment
twenty seven four five hundred thousand
dollar house in
dallas texas okay yeah so you know
the the challenge becomes the challenge
becomes some people now on the flip side
of it are saying
well you should buy realtors are saying
the complete opposite buy today because
money is so cheap don't worry about the
price of the house
buy it because interest rates are so low
i mean look what these bigger guys are
doing they're going buying five billion
dollars
of uh land and properties and they're
paying 25 percent above market prices
if they're doing it why shouldn't we do
it because money is so cheap what do you
say to that
i say yeah money is cheap now but it's
also money is cheap
which has helped boost prices up it's
like a lever you know money money goes
down in the cost
so that's going to help shut prices up
and escalate them the thing is
is that if you put yourself in a
position that's
over your over your means it becomes
more problematic for you because you
want to make sure you can still make
those payments and if you pay
much more for the house then you're able
to handle
what happens if you run into trouble
what happens if the price of that
whatever turbulence within that area
there are risks involved i do think
overall real estate values definitely go
up
and i'd suggest to people to try and
purchase that home but also one of the
things you'll see on there is how many
square feet the home
so that home was going for less than 200
a square foot 222
222 okay so 222 a square foot um
that home at that level compare it to
other homes in your market
of similar style and see am i paying
much more per square foot
than what the market is being if you
start thinking about homes instead of
the price
think about a price per square foot for
a comparable that's a good way to know
if you're doing that
very helpful so let me ask you barry so
let's just say let's just say top
five right okay for example if you're
looking for a spouse if you're looking
for a spouse
number one you have to be you have to be
physically attracted to them whatever
let's just say number two is
you got to be sharing the similar common
values and principles number three is
you know family's got to get along
because you're marrying the family not
whatever number force whatever you go
down the list
i know you have experiences okay yeah
many people ask me these questions so if
i'm asking you
what are the top five markers for me to
look at would you put
price per square feet of the house
number one or what would you put at
number one well
you know you have to live there right so
while the economics
definitely are going to play a major
role i like the house
this is your home so does it fit for
your lifestyle let's think about it
let's go through it
so so is this right we're all taking
notes here all right all good well good
fit is this fit for your home is this
fit for you is this something that
you're going to be comfortable in fit
for you and your family and your family
what a timeline what timeline five years
three years you know this is an
interesting one so the average time
someone lives in a home if it's a first
home if it's your first home your
average time is three and a half years
if it is a home that you
is more not your first home yeah it's
over nine years nine to ten years that
is the typical average time interesting
so so start at home three and a half
years yeah yeah second home
ten years yeah so listen when i was
doing mortgages right and i was
originating more like relationships your
first girlfriend's three years if you
marry somebody's ten years so that's
that's pretty good for a first year
so um so i uh
i i used to do mortgages not one at a
time what really changed my career is i
started doing them two at a time i would
say okay we're gonna do this mortgage
but then
what are we gonna be doing that fits it
part of the puzzle in the next mortgage
and anybody who's taking out a mortgage
do not think one at a time think about
intertwining them because
timeline is the most important thing so
if you are online
if you're if you think that this home
will be right for your time horizon
then yeah the next thing that i would be
thinking about is upside potential
so what is this market's forecasted
appreciation
is this market going to make me money
because now that we've got this is fit
for me now let's start making money
right
if i'm buying a stock it's important
what i buy the stock for
but what's really important is what am i
going to sell it for because if i'm
going to
okay say take peter deal right does it
matter what
if he paid .01 cents or 0.02 cents okay
so um
he what we want to make sure is that
what we're doing
is giving ourselves the ability to make
money in the future
not just to pocket the money but so that
we can keep up
and we can stay ahead of the market so
when we purchase the next home
we can at least keep what should be a
reasonable number for me to be happy
with so if i buy a half a million dollar
house
what should my expectation be five ten
years down the line so for right now
the expectation that we're seeing is
approximately six percent per year
so that means that at six percent this
is where this is where people need to
understand
six percent might not sound very
exciting but it is because if you take a
home let's take a hundred thousand
dollar home i know you can't get a home
for a hundred but let's just
do the exercise a hundred thousand
dollar home you put ten percent down
that means you put ten thousand dollars
down that hundred thousand dollar home
if it appreciates eight percent
so six percent sorry that means the home
made six
thousand dollars six thousand dollars
profit
on a ten thousand dollar investment is a
sixty percent rate of return
sure and if you were to take that home
and you were to say okay
uh at six percent appreciation if it is
not my first home
if i'm going to be there for 12 years or
something like that the home values
doubled
so that home if it's 500 000 12 years
from now it should be worth a million at
six percent
and what you said at six percent is in
five years
the the value of the house should be 676
give or take
there you go okay sounds good so upside
i should be looking at making six
percent
average per year over the next five to
ten years
it depends on the marketplace but that
is a good overall level over time
if i get six percent i won if i did
three percent
and that's going to depend you know
sometimes condos will lag if you're
looking at a condo condos will
definitely be something that will
typically allow you to appreciate the
reason why they land well
they don't appeal to everyone it's not
as broad of an audience it's a little
bit more segmented audience and there's
more restrictions and
you're not going to get typically you're
not going to get as good appreciation as
you would if it was a detached single
family home
okay so number one fit for your family
timeline three to five years number two
is time horizon which we kind of talked
about number three is upside potential
number what's four number four is going
to be making sure you buy it right
okay so how does it compare i'm i wanna
i want you to compare it
cost per square foot as opposed to
looking at price
do cost per square foot for a similar
home and see if you're in the ballpark
and then by the way a template for that
like it should be around 200 bucks per
square foot
it has to be very cool correct now by
the way those are all the tools that we
create for mortgage professionals to
help them do this in a second
on their phone but the thing that that i
think is very important for individuals
who are looking
if they're going to make this purchase
and they're going to find something that
is at least comparable
and they have to pay over then you look
back at one step
and you say okay what's my upside
potential does it pay for me to pay over
asking price
if in five years it's going to be worth
this and i'm paying that
i still get to make a lot of money so if
you're going to make it in the example
you said
so it goes to 700 000 from let's say 500
in five years so five years i make two
hundred thousand dollars if i pay
twenty thousand dollars over asking
price that seems like a good gig
okay that that's that's a reason but
it's knowing that you're gonna get that
six percent over the next five year
period and nobody knows that number
nobody knows what's nobody knows but you
can make educated guesses and a lot of
them are based on demographics
look when we accurately quote them are
based on demographics yes
so when we accurately called the bottom
of the housing market and we also called
we so
this was really interesting because when
i was when i was on tv talking about
there's going to be
problems in the housing market i used to
get like a lot of hate mail what do you
mean you know i said don't take
mortgages with negative amortization
don't take interest only yeah
oh this product and we didn't like the
housing market i actually sold my
company because
we did not like the way the housing
market was and one of the main reasons
was you looked at demographics so let's
just take the demographics today the
median age of a first-time home buyer is
33 years old
which means they were born in 1987 or
1988.
if you look at the birth rates from 33
years ago
what you'll discover is that 32 31
30 29 years ago the birth rates for
whatever reason
skyrocketed that tells us that in the
next four years there's going to be an
enormous
influx of first-time home buyers and
that is going to similar to what
happened in boomers
that's exactly right well it's because
these 33 year olds are millennials
they're they're the kids
70s and 80s now when in 2006 when we
said we don't like the housing market
and remember it was still pretty good in
2006. so we're a little bit early right
but we looked at the demographics and we
saw that in 1973
there was a plunge in birth rates so we
knew the amount of first-time home
buyers coming to the market
was going to be significantly depleted
there was a reason for that
because in january of 1973 abortions
were legalized
birth rates plummet and 33 years later
you don't have people to buy homes at
the same time
builders built the most homes they ever
put up nearly 2 million homes that they
built
so you had overage supply not enough
demand
prices were crashing too much liquidity
in the market people were looking for
where to put it
so what did they do they had to crank up
the volume so they took buyers who
really shouldn't have bought a home
fog up a mirror you can have a mortgage
and
just become no assets no no income no
asset no job no right exactly
580 fico scores zero down what could go
wrong
i mean really so what they did was they
cranked up the buy
issued a lot of mortgages and it wasn't
the mortgage lenders it was wall street
putting out this money saying hey you
got to fill these commitments
so they just allowed the regulations or
the compliance for those to be
very loose and what you had was you had
a big housing bubble that occurred
that's interesting abortion laws
affected real estate 30 years later 32
years later 33 years later what uh 2006.
if you're in any kind of business and
you're not looking at demographics you
really need to do that very
okay so let's go through it again so no
i asked the question what should a buyer
look at before buying a house
barry who's a three times a three-time
uh christopher
ball award with zillow which is who
makes the most accurate prediction of
what's going to happen with uh
uh a value value so you got fit your uh
family goals what is it if you're buying
this house does it fit your goals that
you want with your family time horizon
number two
upside potential is number three which
is a math formula you can use six
percent is victory over five to ten
years
we have that for every single zip code
we can tell you and then four is
buy it based on square feet if you're
gonna use any kind of comps around homes
around your area go based on square feet
what's number five what's your last one
i i think the last one has to be that it
has to fit within your budget
so and listen i'm not saying that this
just because it's listed as number five
doesn't mean for an individual it's not
as important but it has to be within
your budget because
do you want to have a home that's got
great upside this and that but you can
never go out to dinner again
you know do you you wha what does your
and a lot of people do that you know
a lot of people their entire everything
is about the house they got but they
have no license
outside of that exact so look you get
you get to play this game once you get
to live once
you want to balance it is there a
formula
there's formulas for what you qualify
for but those formulas
affect every single family differently
because they're spending it and what i
mean by that is you know it's like hey
save 10 of your money you know hey
you know give 10 percent that's good
that's the richest man in babylon book
right
is there a formula of your monthly
income you make five thousand after
taxes thirty percent of your there is
a ballpark around thirty percent just to
keep it simple okay around thirty
percent
but that'll qualify you however you also
have to qualify for
about about forty percent including all
of your debts
so one thing that people don't realize
is that don't forget about the debt
the debt is really important it means 30
is the following if you're making
and by the way are you saying net income
or you're saying gross income so tax
taxes have to come out too of that but
it's 40 percent of your gross income
handles your mortgage check this i'm
giving you round numbers
i get that but if you're saying if i'm
if i'm netting eight grand a month
okay if i'm netting eight grand a month
thirty percent of that so now you've
got twenty four hundred but then the
bigger number which really affects most
people
is forty percent of that or thirty two
hundred dollars has to do the mortgage
the taxes the insurance if there's
mortgage insurance but less than twenty
percent down
maintenance if you're buying the condo
and in addition to that
all of your debts your car payments your
minimum you know what this means so this
means
alimony child support that loans that
500 000
house we just looked at the only person
that should buy it is somebody that's
netting eight thousand dollars a month
somebody who's pretty much pretty much
maybe maybe more
but it doesn't have to be by the way
there could be two incomes too of course
but what's net net is 12 a month so
you're making 11 or something like that
yeah you're making 150 so that means a
500 000
house is lived by somebody that's making
a household income of 150 per year
pre-taxes but but patrick this is where
your personal situation think about that
that's
why the median house is if somebody
likes to eat home every night and
they're not going to do that
they may have more discretionary income
maybe they're going to go to 3 000 right
somebody who likes you know
clothes shopping and vacations more you
have to that's why i said
your means and your lifestyle as the
last how much would you add i know you
gave the five points here which was very
helpful the audience is uh uh uh
taking a lot of notes with this and
they're sending messages here number
five
for me what would you put value for uh
your the house was built you know
meaning is it a
2005 build it's so 2005 at 222 square
feet
uh dollars per square foot versus 2017
how much value do you put on what year
the house was the home was built
so you can almost estimate that homes
are going to be around for like 60 or 70
years right and the average home in the
united states today is close to 40 years
old i mean think about that it's 41 to
be exactly
average average average age is 40 years
old 41. so let's
so a 10-year difference probably doesn't
mean too much patrick in your example
so long as it's in good condition that's
why if you're going to buy a home
without an expense an inspection you
could be putting yourself at some risk
okay i i think that interesting
challenge there's nothing to them
yeah so 10 years so if i have a house
one is built in 2016. one is built in
2006.
you're looking at the house the 2006 is
250 a square foot
the 2016 is 280 square foot
how do you judge that it's close enough
it's close you don't care so you would
go 16 or 16.
it's it's it's just we said do i like
the home that's number one got it but
then after that how does it compare to
other homes like that on square footage
i got another question that just came up
here folks if you got questions here
post it on twitter because we're
actually going through kai if you want
to go on twitter and pull up all the
hashtag pbdpodcast
hashtag pbdpodcast you can put my handle
in there it's easier to find at
patrickbetdavid the question is so this
is from
chile childress what a great name chili
childress
so i'm on the verge of putting my house
two-bedroom
one-bath ranch that was down to studs
remodel one year ago on the market i
bought it last
july here on southeastern mass for 275
and it's now an estimated 321.
so he went from 275 800
to 321 should i sell now or hold a
little longer
okay so a couple of things so first of
all because i happen to see it people
are asking about debt
income ratios yeah i said 40 remember i
said round number could you exceed that
certainly could go up a little bit
there's going to be compensating i'm
just giving you round numbers so people
could do quick
by the way i like the fact that you're
giving conservative numbers because
a lot of people are saying go higher i
would much rather go where you're going
and go the higher enough yes
now with this particular case here's
what you have to think of so it appears
that you made a profit and
if you're married the first 500 000 of
profit is free
if you're single the first 250 000 of
profit is free from tax
what is that a homestead right there no
that's just the federal income tax so
there's no there's no first home by
homeowner or
anybody anybody anybody so what what we
have to think of here is
okay how much money did you put into it
how much money did you pay for closing
costs getting in
how much are you going to spend if you
list it with a real estate agent or
whatever to get
out and then where are you going to go
so before you ask
should i sell i think you should ask
yourself should i be buying what do i
want to buy i think you need to go right
back to that list
does this home no longer fit my needs
and if it doesn't then i have to buy
something can i find something first
and then you can put your house and make
that decision folks barry habib if
you're enjoying today's podcast smash
the thumbs up button
as well as subscribe to the channel if
you want to hear more barry he'll be
maybe even bringing him back to talk
more and to talk about real estate
uh press that thumbs up button again if
you've got questions hashtag pbd
podcasts on twitter
uh great stuff we're learning so far
five things when you're looking into
buying a house number one does it fit
your family goals number two is time
horizon
number three is the potential upside
potential of the house number four is
uh uh look at the cost per square feet
and number five is your budget
typically thirty to forty percent of
your gross monthly income
you can get a little bit more aggressive
than that but thirty percent's the
number typically to look at so patrick
if we can i want to talk a little bit
about something that has to do with
creating some wealth for you with real
estate sure and i know we focused a
little bit about buying a home but
the homeownership rate in the united
states is 66 so perhaps 66 percent of
people are listening
is that average is that higher is that
lower what's the number
the highest that it ever was was in 2005
when it
was at 69.4 so let's say roughly 70
home ownership rate was the highest
that's when they were handing out houses
like for nothing
yes exactly so it's 66 it's healthy
certain markets like in california it's
typically 55 that's how they've dealt
with the
the costs going up is it shaped a little
bit of the homeownership rate however
that 55 percent
still overwhelms the available supply 40
is 55 55 but that but
but that 55 is more than the supply and
that's why prices keep going up
so what i want to talk about is the
people that are listening that own a
home
you really need to look at your mortgage
situation right now because there's
things that you could do
that could set your kids up for college
that could set you up for retirement and
that can create enormous wealth and give
you the life
that you really deserve and use your
mortgage
people look at a mortgage and it's crazy
they look like they're buying a flat
screen tv and all they care about is the
rate
that's not what the important thing is
the important thing is the strategy
so for example what we see a lot of and
we advise a lot of mortgage
professionals to do this and we get
hundreds and thousands of stories of
people that have changed individuals
life so
let's just say if you have a mortgage
right now and you're saying i shouldn't
refinance because
my rate is i don't let's say you got in
it two and a half percent
and you see rates today a little over
three and let's even go crazy say they
go up a little bit to three and a
quarter three and a half
people are not thinking about
refinancing but what you're forgetting
is like any good
coach in football would say you know
take what the defense gives you so what
we've been given here is this
appreciation
so two things have happened to your home
it's appreciated and you've been making
your mortgage payments so you've
amortized the loan
you've gained equity in just the past
year anybody who's paying mortgage
insurance
you probably can refinance and save that
but the magic really happens
with your debt because if you were to
say what we see oftentimes is let's just
take a typical family 20 000 in credit
card debt
one car loan they've got a chevy it's 29
car loan they've got a little bit of
best buy they've got a little bit of
nordstroms or whatever it is
a few things nothing crazy you take that
family
you say okay let's take your debt pay it
all off
included in the mortgage even if the
rate's one percent higher
right so going from two and a half to
three and a half let's just say
you could save about eighteen hundred
dollars a month in cash flow but here's
the real key
don't take that eighteen hundred dollars
of found money and go blow it
take that eighteen hundred dollars and
pour it back into the mortgage
so if you bought your home three years
ago now you got 27 years left normally
yep
you change it to 11 years left on your
mortgage
no payments in five years you gain a
hundred and ten thousand dollars
in ten years you gain 270 thousand
dollars in 11 years when the things paid
off
320 000 benefit that'll pay for your
kids college
and you saved 15 years of making your
mortgage payment at 4
000 bucks a month it's the best
retirement plan you could have there you
go
bury a beep okay on how to do kai's back
they're taking notes
did you get that guy did you learn yes
okay good now let me let me
read you something that's going on here
this is a realtor.com story
the housing markets show signs of
softening
has it topped out right over the past
few weeks the rate of price growth has
begun to slow fewer buyers are seeking
mortgages to purchase homes
the competition for available homes
while still formidable may not be quite
as intense as it's been
and this could provide buyers a sorely
needed opening the markets topping out
says mark zandy
chief economist at moody's analytics
it's starting to show cracks it feels
like we've hit the apex and we're moving
to the other side of it
that does not mean there's a bubble on
the verge of popping and the prices are
about to plummet in a free
free fall reminiscent of the last
housing bus that we had according to
economists and housing experts
some of april's rise was due to the
comparison to a year earlier april 2020
was the beginning of cover 19 and was
local restrictions general fear over the
virus hampered real estate markets but
that's not what the whole story is
january of this year
when prices were up 15.4 compared to
january of 2020
which was well before the pandemic so
then the next story i'll put both of
them together and you tell me your
thoughts on this
is another housing bubble building this
is a street story
same exact thing they quoted mark zandy
as well
but it says the price has dominated
financial news recently for
renters the price of an average
apartment takes up
an even greater ever greater share of
personal income every year this is
particularly true in big cities
where a one-bedroom apartment can often
cost between
twenty five hundred dollars to three
thousand dollars a month but the real
headlines have been in the market for
single family housing in many
communities home prices
have increased by thirty to fifty
percent in just the past two years
this has led the median prices home over
twenty thousand dollars nationwide to
nearly five hundred thousand dollars in
the towns and suburbs
near major cities which is kind of what
you were talking about so there's so
much misconception there's a lot of
better
tell us what it is okay so there's a lot
so first of all i know mark mark's a
friend okay
interestingly enough at john burns
conference three years ago we debated
this
i said the housing market was going up
three years ago he was not in big
in favor of the housing market going up
the way i was but uh burn right
there but so so i understand where
mark's coming from but what you're
seeing there
what you're seeing there is what you're
seeing is number one
again the use of median home price this
is a misconception median home price is
not appreciation
now somebody said 15.4 appreciation i
have no idea where they pulled that out
of because that's just wrong
there's no way it's 15.4 percent the
latest data that we have
and i said i said we're going to get new
data today from from case shiller which
is the gold standard
this is the way you really supposed to
measure it but the most recent was 13
again which is what you said earlier
that's really really hot levels of
appreciation
but in order for there to first of all
when they talk
here's the main concept we have to
understand
when you look at the housing market
there's the housing market that's the
driver of gdp that generates economic
activity
and then there's the housing market i'm
buying a home for myself and i want to
know am i going to make money am i going
to lose money i'm going to create wealth
two different ways to look at it and
what the consumer gets confused on
is the media looks at the housing market
as the driver of gdp
and sales are slowing sales are not
slowing
because the market's bad sales are
slowing because there's nothing for sale
there's nothing to buy so if i had when
when you know the new airpods came out
the airpod pros and you wanted them
but you go to apple and they didn't have
them in stock it doesn't mean sales are
slowing
there's so much demand that they don't
have enough of it so sales are slow
because you don't have enough supplies
same thing in the housing market
the other thing people get confused upon
any person who looks at stocks
we know that it's a stock market but
really it's a market of
stocks you can go to healthcare you can
go to technology you can go to
uh whatever you have many different
sectors biotech right so
a dozen major sectors exactly in the
housing market
you have to divide it into sectors
there's your first time home buyer
sector
there's your you know move-up buyer
sector there's your more affluent areas
there's the premium priced homes
so look at all of those as sectors
interesting point of view
so if you if you do it then the picture
gets clearer because then you could say
okay well
sales are slowing but where are they
slowing they're certainly not slowing on
the upper end they're picking up they're
doubling
they're slowing on the lower now the
majority of homes do take place on the
lower end okay
we know that but there's just not a lot
of inventory because remember
in any market if you're going to say
there's a bubble what's the definition
of it the definition of a bubble
is that there is too much supply not
enough demand
and therefore prices will come down we
have the exact opposite and the demand
is going to get stronger
barry i remember when guys were speaking
the way you were speaking okay everybody
was saying oh my god there was two
communities back in 2006. it was the
angelo
what was his name oh my gosh he looked
like
he looked like uh he's one of these
mafia bosses right very good looking guy
very tan like you a good looking guy
like you and he would get up and say hey
you know it's going to continue it's
going to do this it's going to do that
countrywide round people oh my gosh
he's right and you know there was a
new century what was it uh uh there was
a bunch of these companies out there
that were doing a lot of loans new
century i believe new central new
century i was
killing it yeah i used to speak on tour
for now you remember the correspondents
that were paying on the back end which
was ridiculous guys i'm working 400
grand a month like oh my gosh
this is going to continue like this and
they were convincing they were so
convincing then there was
the michael burries of the world like
listen guys this shit's not going to
last like this for a long time
so i think the biggest thing you know
the camp i was in i was in 2006 i was
getting hate mail per say the market was
frothy well here's my question for you
here's my question for you
who the hell should the audience believe
in everybody's here we go okay
everybody's an expert who should we both
so here we go go for it number one when
you take a look at the comparison to
yep let's do it okay so first of all
there were 3.7 million homes for sale in
2007.
today there's 1.05 million homes for
sale so the supplies
that's a big expansion 3.7 million homes
for sale in 2007 today 1.05 million and
the latest data will show that that
number
has been cut in the third three million
less homes but wait
wait hold on here's more importance in
yeah everyone in the united states lived
under 116 million rupees there was 116
million households
the latest data is from 2020 there were
128 million households 12 more
12 million more households three million
fewer homes and you wonder why prices
are going up how can that market go down
now somebody might say
okay forbearance foreclosure we should
talk about that because another big
misconception the media gets it
completely wrong on this so first of all
most of them don't know how to spell
forbearance forget about understanding
it and by the way it's kind of hard to
spell
so when you take a look at forbearance
what does that mean think of it
as a pause button on your player
you pause the payments now when they
came out with the cares act
what they did was they rushed to bring
this out there and they made the
forbearance
so that you didn't have to prove
hardship so a lot of people said wait a
minute
i don't have to make my payment there's
no penalty there's no interest for 12
months
how does forbearance work when it's all
over at the end of the
forbearance period you don't have to
make a payment here's all my back
payments
it kind of rides along your first
mortgage as a second mortgage with no
interest no payments
and you're able to pay that off and
satisfy it when you either refinance
pay off your home or sell your home so
that's when you so those are going to be
very staggered it's not going to cause
any turbulence in the market
and if those properties came on if there
were a problem with them it's like
dropping a water can on the desert you
know we need the inventory
but now think about the resumption of
payments so
a big portion of people who took
forbearance they didn't need it
so many people who took forbearance got
their home got their jobs back
if they did need it so they should have
no problem because they qualify sure
there will be a segment of the
population that the through forbearance
heaven forbid we feel awful for these
poor folks but they now can't make their
payment
what the vast vast vast majority will be
able to do
put their home on the market probably
sell it in a week pocket a ton of cash
from it
so they're not going to let those homes
go into the marketplace
under foreclosure or under duress this
is not 2 000
listen to this in 2009 26 of homes
owned more on their mortgage than the
value of the home
today there is less than two percent
where the value of the mortgage is
higher than the value of the home this
is what they call underwater yeah
underwater 26 in 2009 exactly now it's
only two percent
less than two percent so it's not even
comparable to two thousand and here's
the other thing too
let's talk let's talk about loans in 90
days delinquent loans 90 days liquid
people look at that
and i saw there was an article that you
had so they say okay loans 90 days
delinquent
2 percent of loans in 90 days look in a
normal market
it's 1.5 so we're people forget they
just show the headline and they don't
show
what the variance is we just went
through a pandemic so yes that has gone
up a little bit
loan's actually in foreclosure it is a
quarter of one percent
so that's one out of four hundred homes
you add to that
the homes that are on free and clear
which is 34 now you're talking if you
took a helicopter you looked over 500
600 homes
only one of those homes is in
foreclosure that's one too many but now
the number says an estimated 10 million
americans are behind in the mortgage
payments and 1.7 million or
90 days past due that's two percent four
times as many as the uh before the
pandemic that's incorrect information
that is not four times as many that's
from sun
sentinel and the sun sentinel is wrong
because if you do the math on it as you
probably did in your head that's two
percent
right roughly 10 million on what 10 no
not 10 million go to the 90 days plus
1.7 million okay so that's there's 80 86
million homes so
roughly two percent okay right so then
you got two percent of homes
used to be one and a half percent the
variance is that's not four times about
they may be talking about the 10 million
our past due
but if they're counting people that went
into forbearance yeah okay
but they had a free pass they had a
whole pass not to make their payments
biggest difference is when you're saying
3.7 million to 1 million
that's just ridiculous i mean so if you
look at the markers to see what happened
in 06 versus today
i remember all the homes that builders
were building like crazy riverside
county
had a 64 foreclosure rate at one point
you'd go the literally you're walking
the streets six out of ten homes it's
trash no one's living there
somebody just walked away from it
because patrick was in california this
is an 0708 it was
like detroit riverside was ugly people
were gaming the housing market to try
and make profit because it was going up
and people were flipping homes
so one person was buying five homes
they didn't qualify for any of the five
they could fog up five mirrors but they
got mortgages on five homes
today that one person is buying a home
for the home they need to live in that's
like
the movie the big short michael berry
was like talking to the girl and steve
carell and
there was a stripper that had five uh
that was the part
yeah yeah yeah matter of fact that
stripper was in rock of ages just so you
know that good girl by the way
yeah so go back good investor yeah
question kai pull up twitter
pull up twitter pull up twitter katarina
asks a question saying longer loan
and smaller payments or shorter loans
higher payments
katarina you got to go with what fits
your lifestyle the best and if you have
a
if you have a way to take the difference
so let's just say
longer term and smaller payments right
so let's just use some numbers let's say
it's a
it's a thousand dollar payment versus a
fifteen hundred dollar payment
my question to you katharine is what are
you gonna do if you could afford the
payment so now you have both options so
what are you gonna do with the 500 bucks
and where are you going to invest it
because if you do invest it into your
mortgage into a shorter term
that's going to give you a quicker
payoff it's going to put you in a
position we're going to be building
equity over time you don't have to wait
until the loans paid off
you're building much more equity it's
got an amazing effect people don't
realize it
so what happens is is that when you make
additional payments on your mortgage
you get the benefit because then every
single subsequent payment
is based on the lower remaining
principal balance so a greater portion
of
every single payment after that more
goes towards principle
so it builds on itself look if you have
another
80 of america that's good it's really
good
yeah it is really good of course but if
you have
a business opportunity if you could put
that 500 a month in something that's
gonna generate
you know eight nine ten less than five
percent it's not good because where are
you going to put it safely in the bank
you know
so the definition of the risk-free rate
about this is about one percent
it's very good answer because you're
giving the the audience perspective to
know
that it may make sense for some and it
may not make sense for uh others but
let me let me go to a different route
here you know there's two names that
keep coming up
okay and these two names we've talked to
danielle the martino booth which you
guys have uh
friends you guys have she had a lot of
good things to say about you by the way
she had very good things to say about
you when you and i were meeting she said
patrick i know you and barry are
considering doing something you're
considering doing something with barry
you know just won't let you know i vouch
for him he's a good guy so danielle a
lot of good things say about you and we
you know how we feel about danielle
is a homie she's a family and she's been
with us now for a while creating content
down the middle with daniel she's
crushing it
um question for you when it comes down
to two names we got
powell which is obviously the fed
chairman of the first
and then we have yellen okay which she
sometimes forgets and she thinks she
still has powell's job right she still
thinks that's her job right
which of those two is creating the
biggest havoc and which of those two has
the most influence
on what direction rates could go to and
what direction real estate could go to
the next 12 24 36 months
okay so we should also mention janet
yellen used to be the fed chair i didn't
think she was very of course i didn't
think she was a good fed chair
but she used to be the fed chair and
what janet yellen's job now is treasury
secretary besides
signing the money that comes out you
know the treasury secretary signs the
cash that you get
is janet yellen sells the president's
agenda
so what's her job to do is not what's
good for you what's good for me what's
good for people listening
it is to sell the president's agenda
let's understand that right
so she's a salesperson right now she had
different responsibilities as a fed
chair
but it is crazy and maddening to hear
this woman
talk about the wealth gap that's out
there and wealth inequality
when her and ben bernanke created it
because what they decided to do
was now who knows what the motivation
was it might have been pure motivation
but what they decided to do was they
took rates to these unbelievably low
levels begin quantitative easing
and by taking rates to where you were
punished for savings
they gave us as we all know tina tina
which stands for there is no alternative
and bernanke used to call this the
wealth effect
and what he said was if we stop people
from saving and force them to all put
their money collectively it's the same
thing that
the reddit boards are doing okay it's
just on a grander scale
it's no different than the reddit meme
stocks except they did well
wall street back it's the exact same
thing except now
they've got the whole country doing it
because i'm going to punish you for
saving
i'm gonna let you earn less than one
percent in your savings
and the only place you could put your
money is in the stock market
and by doing so everybody did that the
stock market has been on what
kind of a ride since then we all know
okay so
when you see that occur by the way folks
i want you to hear
can you say that one more time say the
last 30 seconds one more time what
they've done
this is very important they punished you
to save your money to put into market
market say that one more time
so by taking the the benefit of saving
money
people used to say i could plan for my
retirement because i could put my money
in the bank safely get
four percent five percent six months
money market cd save an account you have
many options
it's safe i can plan for america now i
can never retire like that
okay i can't do that and what would
happen to those
people is that they were forced
people that shouldn't be taking risks
grandma was now
taking risks and putting them in the
stock market
fortunately because everybody did it it
created growth in the stock market as we
have seen for the last 12 years
right however here's the big point is
that
not everybody's in the stock market so
this is what created the haves and
have-nots
to a much more exacerbated way because
now people
fifty percent of families were able to
go in the stock market fifty percent of
families benefited
those fifty percent that were left
behind were left way behind
and it is sickening to hear her talk
about it as if she had nothing to do
with it
because her and ben bernanke created
this
mm-hmm it's the wall street versus
mainstream approach right there
wall street versus main street approach
exactly right so you're not a fan of
yelling or what she's i think she
apologizes implemented i don't i don't
think that she you know well currently
again she's a salesperson
so you know you always have to be a
little leery of salespeople because
they'll have their agenda right mm-hmm
um what would you say to somebody says
well barry's a salesperson
he's got an agenda he's in real estate
well every individual has their own
agenda right
where you where you stand depends on
where you sit right so you have
you have your point of view and
everybody's trying to do that i'm
offering an opinion which is just that
it's an opinion that's the way it should
be taken right it's not
uh there's some things that are factual
that some of the data we spoke about is
factual but in this case it's an opinion
i don't think she did a very good job as
as the fed chair as well
um i think that she had chances where
she could have raised rates and did not
do so i think that
i think that the fed gets frightened
because who wants to be
named as the fed chair who let the
economy tank
and that's the problem jay powell who
you mentioned has right now because when
he tried in 2013 to taper
the market went into a tantrum and he
backed off now that was taking the fed's
balance sheet from 4.3 trillion to 3.8
trillion
and they say can't do it now the fed's
balance sheet is eight trillion dollars
that's
that's a scary thought when you think
about that so let's let's say this is a
trillion dollar balance let's do this
this is fun because everybody is
listening they're hearing trillion
trillion trillion so listen if i said to
you hey let's do a business deal cash
deal
and i said patrick i'm gonna pay you
cash a hundred thousand dollars cash i
bring a brief
big suitcase in i open up the suitcase
and it's hundred dollar bills
it's very anticlimactic it's a four inch
stack
a million dollars is a 40 inch stack of
hundred dollar bills if you could stack
bills this high it's a million bucks a
billion
takes you to the empire state building
twice
eight trillion if i stack them up one on
top of each other and then tilted it on
its side it'd go from here
to california and back five thousand
four hundred miles
that's what eight trillion dollars is in
hundred dollar bills it is an
enormous sum of money and we get blind
to it
because we constantly hear it and we
become immune
yeah so so then the question becomes
then the question becomes when
we're talking about interest rates how
likely and
how soon do you predict the rates could
go up to six percent
can it happen if yes how soon can that
happen okay so so let's understand
um there's a few things occurring right
now so i'm going to answer that question
but let's give some background so i do
think there might be some policy change
coming in august so it's we think
i think that when we get the jackson
hole meeting by the fed that has in the
past been where they change policy
now we heard from the st louis fed
president bullard
we also just heard from
um another fed president who was talk oh
uh we were talking we were talking about
the fact that the housing market might
be overheating
and when we oh this was the boston fed
president
um i'll get in a minute
the boston freight president talked
about the housing market overheating
so what they're saying is that the fed
should stop buying mortgage-backed
securities
eric rosengren is who it was yes so the
two of them now have been talking about
the
the market overheating so i think come
the 26th
27th 28th of august at that meeting they
may say that the fed's going to begin to
taper their purchases mortgage-backed
securities
how much are they buying well they lie
they said they were buying 40 billion
we started calling them out on it so
what did they do they removed the data
from the new york fed.org so you
couldn't find it that easily
recently they purchased about 80 billion
in a month so now they change their
language to 40 billion
to 100 uh to at least 40 billion a month
but it's closer to 100 billion
a month that they're buying so they're
buying the market it's called yield
curve control we haven't really done it
since the 1940s
but they've pegged yields and they said
we want to keep it here
think about how crazy it is inflation
erodes the buying power
the inflation rate right now let's call
it three and a half percent is the core
rate stripping out food and energy
the 10-year treasury yields one and a
half percent so i'm getting one and a
half but my money's eroding at three and
a half percent that should never happen
how sustained how long can that be
sustainable it shouldn't be sustainable
but when the fed is buying so much in
treasuries to keep and suppress that
yield down artificially
if inflation's three and a half you've
got to make a spread on that it's got to
be four and a half
that's where the 10-year treasury should
be with three and a half percent in
places now i think inflation will abate
i think inflation will come to i know
the fed loves transitory there are
certain things that will stick
but look patrick if you take a look at
some of the reasons why the the numbers
in cpi went up and the numbers in the pc
personal consumption expenditures a
different inflation report that the fed
loves
the reason why they went up is the
reopening because what really went up
is uh sporting event sales went up 10
hotels went up
nine percent airlines went up 10 and
then you have the chip shortage issue
so it made of vehicles go up five
percent and compute i'm sorry ten
percent of the
computers go five percent because of
that it made a big jump in cpi but those
sectors combined
only represent seven percent of the
economy the other 93
only went up three tenths of a percent
so we have some inflation it's not as
high as being stated
it will calm down but rates will never
go to six percent never go to six
percent no at least not while
i'm around i don't think because what
has to cause that is you need enormous
inflation technology is advancing so
much it is keeping costs lower
artificial intelligence robotics
technology in general will continue to
make things cheaper and cheaper and
cheaper and cheaper
and in addition to that the supply of
labor that we have is pretty strong
we're in a position that if jobs become
eliminated
you're going to see costs continue to be
pressured lower and also global
globalization has kept so so arthur
laffer whom uh
i love him you know who he is i spoke to
him uh was it last week
last week we had him on or something two
weeks ago i said that what's your
biggest concern
what do you stand with inflation he says
i'm not at all worried about inflation
because he said the leading indicator of
inflation to me is
gold prices and go gold prices and gold
prices haven't moved and i asked
danielle and danielle's like no
inflation is here
there's nothing we can do about it it's
going to continue to go up where do you
stand with inflation love art danielle's
right
inflation will be something some
inflation is going to be sticky
okay some especially on the wages that's
the stickiest are we going to go into
hyperinflation mode or no no no
we're not going to do that although
there's a lot of money sloshing around
but no hyperinflation
and and you can't just go buy gold
anymore
because you know the boomer rocks of
gold used to be a good indicator
and since the beginning of time they say
one ounce of gold should buy one fine
man's suit right
and that probably is still true today so
with gold that a little over 1700
an ounce i think that you know that
still holds true but gold isn't the only
indicator because of the rise of
cryptocurrencies
so if you don't believe in fiat money
because the printing press
you had the alternative gold before but
now you also have the alternative crypto
so gold if it were not for crypto
gold would be at a much higher level all
right so you're not too worried about
inflation you don't think rates are
going to get to six percent anytime soon
concerned about inflation but i do think
it will abate and i think some of it was
going to be sticky and stay
all right but here's the thing that we
have to understand is that debt and i
know most people don't
get this and this i'm going to give a
hat tip to one of my mentors lacie hunt
was
one of those brilliant minds out there
so he taught me this
and showed me this but debt we know this
every time in history and everywhere in
the world
the higher the debt the lower the rates
because what debt
does is it drives economic activity
slower which prevents inflation if you
have a family that wants to buy a car
when we were kids you still have a piggy
bank used to have a piggy bank
you'd save up you break the piggy bank
you go buy it great as adults who wants
to do that we want instant gratification
we want it now yep
so we use credit to take a future
purchase and make it today
if a family wants to buy a car they go
out and they buy that car today using
credit using debt
and it creates economic activity
economic activity what that will do is
the dealership the manufacturer the
salesperson they all make money to spend
money
but it has a short life what sticks is
now that family has a thousand dollar a
month debt for the next 60 months which
means they could buy less
and it's the same thing with our economy
cares act one and two
was 2.8 trillion dollars that was in
march and april of 2020 by october the
economy was already slowing
the gdp for the united states was 4.3 in
in the fourth quarter was 0.4 it was all
front loaded
and i the reason why there's such panic
to generate these additional stimulus
plans right now
is because they know that the sugar rush
will begin to slow okay all right so
we'll see what happened i mean obviously
it's great to hear different
perspectives but you know the audience
has to make up their minds
uh the one part that was very
uh eye opening was to saying 0708 when
the whole michael berry big short
happened there was 3.7 million
inventory today's a million that's a
very big difference an indicator because
you got almost way too much and then 12
million increase in
family households you're talking about
12 million from what from 116 million to
128 billion was a number give or take so
and patrick remember birth rates stayed
low
from 1973 to 1979
which means you did not have the influx
of people coming yeah
and and now things have turned a little
bit because the exact opposite what's
the generation they're saying that's
bigger than boomers is it gen x or is it
millennials millennials are bigger than
boomers now 80 million versus 76 million
so
if that's the case you're saying real
estate's going to continue to rise over
the next few years
let's hope it doesn't get too far ahead
of itself but let's say it this way
it should be well supported okay all
right sounds good let's take a little
bit of a different kind of a story so
imagine if i make a salary of 174 400
okay give or take in the last 20 i've
had a job this job pays me a hundred and
seventy four thousand four hundred
dollars today
it was a lot less 25 years ago but today
pays me 174 000
should i be able to afford to have a 41
million dollar house in lake tahoe
if you're if you're let me ask that
question one more time i make a salary
of 174. i've been doing it for about 25
years
should i be able to afford a 41 million
auto house in lake tahoe and it wasn't
passed down you know house from family
to me should i be able to have a house
41 million
in lake tahoe only if you're senator
dianne feinstein that's right pull up
the picture guy
so dianne feinstein lists her
41 million dollar lake tahoe estate
check this out 41 million dollars if
anybody's watching this they want to
make an offer it's right there it's
beautiful
okay it's three properties contains 11
bedrooms
nine bathroom the bathrooms the compound
sits on nearly five
acres of land the 172 foot pier
extending into the water check that out
look how beautiful that is
this can be for this can be yours for
simply a 41 million
dollar offer i pulled up looking up uh
the richest senators we have in america
richest centers we have in america
number one was romney
number two was uh and romney you know he
made his money as an entrepreneur for a
longest time he's done well for himself
and it's senator mark
warner which has got a net worth of 215
million dollars
and at fourth place we have dianne
feinstein
88 million dollar net worth as of 2018
blum capital private equity firm founded
in 1975 by her husband richard blum is a
source of most of the wealth
there you have it 41 million dollar home
and the hotel
that they made their money into the
husband and wife yes hotel chain is how
they made their money i mean listen more
power to them the reality of it is
there are 40 million dollar homes in the
market right now and people are buying
them okay
uh uh you know right here another house
just uh
some guy some saudi oil guy just put his
penthouse for sale in new york for 174
million dollars
after he bought it seven eight years ago
for 86 million dollars
do you know what i just said 86 million
dollar penthouse he bought he's got in
the market right now 174 million dollars
in where new york in new york 174
million dollar
townhouse and not townhouse what do you
call it penthouse he's got
for sale so it's not a bad time to be in
the real estate market especially the
high end because they're selling for
more than ever but again congratulations
to diane
we hope you get the offer you're
expecting to get a bunch of cash offers
we're rooting for you diane
it is what it is somebody's got to do it
okay uh did you see the game yesterday
clippers against the uh
are you a basketball guy or not really
clubs played the sons last night
more baseball football more baseball a
bunch of guys were wearing masks
apparently this mask thing is coming
back to l.a lake
urges everyone to start wearing masks
again
indoors as delta variant spreads this is
an la time story which is not in there
this just came out
more than three in five californians
have gotten at least one vaccine dose to
date but fewer than half are truly
vaccinated
fully vaccinated according to the data
from u.s sensor centers for
disease and control and prevention
california has won the nation's highest
vaccination rates and that has many
experts confident that the delta strain
won't cause the kind of kova 19
surges seen over the last year i was
watching the clippers game
and i'm seeing who's the center for the
clips who's the big guy
zubach who's got a bit of an injury he's
got this mask on
on the sidelines that's the biggest mask
i've ever seen i'm looking at all the
fans
fans don't have any masks yeah the
clippers have masks on and players are
not putting masks i get a message on
instagram saying you know california is
back on putting masks on what do you
think about this mask situation right
now in california
it's just california to be specific
they've obviously
overreacted to some of this i mean you
have a state like florida which
did not have mass mandates and you come
here and kind of do what you want to do
california and no difference in rates by
the way of disease
right well yeah that's true then the
well new york is obviously
way worse than california from what i
understand they don't even put masks on
they put like scarfs on masks on you
know
it's just you know different strokes for
different folks at the other day it's so
weird because you go to the games that
people in the crowd doesn't wear a mask
but then uh when you're playing you
don't have to wear a mask when you go to
the bench you put on the mask
and then some people do the old i i i
just put it over my mouth but not over
my nose and some people keep it under
their neck
and then some people like have worn the
same mask for the last 12 months they
haven't replaced the mask the mask
clearly is like old and uh
rotten and dirty there's just no
uniformity to the mass thing there's
only just one visual that makes sense to
me
it's only one visual and it's the same
it was a year and a half ago as it is
today okay when i see
tyron liu wearing a mask while he's
doing an interview with espn
unzoom by himself like i'm telling you
that's like wearing a condom going to
sleep with no one to have sex with
like you just have a condom on for no
reason what do you have i mean is it
just
what are you doing with that there's no
it makes no lun these are smart people
like okay i'm looking at the zoom
how the hell can i get the virus from
you
on the zoom or the people driving in
their car yeah with them that's a
classic one
those are those i take pictures of i
mean i like to take pictures with those
guys on selfies because
it's a it's a league of their own that's
what they've got going on that's right
it's like wearing a seat belt when
you're walking yeah makes no sense no
you got you you you're parked
okay on a phone call you're you're
making a phone call with two somebody
and you put your seat belt down
let me put my sleep on before we talk on
the phone like there's certain logic
that just makes
zero sense these are people you would
hope these are people you would
you know make fun of but today it's seen
as responsible
you both made points that made me think
about a story that you were talking
about too and that's what's going on
with teaching the fa
faa individuals tsa individuals rather
more self-defense and i think this is a
result of since january 1st has been 3
000 incidents of unruly passengers but
when you look into it it's all
mass compliance and it's frustrating
because i fly a lot
there's no uniformity as you said some
flight attendants are pretty reasonable
about it some it's like
boy it is like really super frustrating
dictatorship
it's like they finally got this power
and they could be mean and nasty and
whatever and
look i know it's not an easy job for
them okay so i respect that
but why don't you just make it so that
if you're vaccinated get a vaccine right
if you're vaccinated why do you need to
wear a mask
or why do you need to prove it you want
to take a risk on your own take a risk
on your own some people as you said
have sex without protection right so
they take their risks they know what
they're doing oh
that's that's fine if you're going to
have to take the risk of having sex
without protection
my worry is people that don't have a sex
partner who are wearing condoms
that's my word i'm not worried about
those guys that's to each his own that's
a libertarian
practicing safe sex it's very exciting
understand that part
that's really the key word practicing
yeah so um so i i think i think that
when you when you look at it you would
say look
if you have if you have a concern wear a
mask
yeah well i think that's what people are
doing they keep moving the goalposts you
wear a mask you don't wear a mask if
it's up to you individual liberties
you're on a plane you don't you have to
wear a mask but when you take a sip of
the water
you get to take the mask off and if
you're eating a snack you can in between
how many times have people have went to
eat something and then boom your mask is
on boom now i got pasta on my face by
the way
did you hear what uh uh what's his name
what uh uh uh what what's the place we
always talk about kai
uh um it's a little country you know the
country that
is low regulation entrepreneurs are
living there singapore singapore
you know what singapore said with covet
moving we've seen this data or no pull
up singapore covet
uh flew just type in singapore covid
flew just put covet flew okay let me see
if it shows up
i was just about to give you credit for
spelling things right
no no i never go back to the zombie
looks to live virus okay right there
go to a south china morning post yeah
right there click on that
uh singapore preparing to live with
endemic
covet 19 as residents grow battle weary
of pandemic
so what what singapore is now doing is
the following singapore is officially
treating the covid
okay as flu meaning it's no longer is a
big deal look go back to your life do
what you were doing
no longer the over regulatory stuff that
they're going to anyways i mean you see
what's going on in florida we ended up
in florida you see what's going on in
texas
texas was a great place to be while you
were doing covet business didn't take a
massive hit
you saw what happened a couple of these
states and california is apparently
still going back to what it was before
even after all the people got the
vaccinations it's also easy
to do the monday morning quarterback
thing with covid when this first
happened
and i'm not trying to be political or
anything like that no never seen
anything like this in the last hundred
years so you don't know
the severity of it should we wear a mash
should we social justice should we not
we didn't have a vaccine a year ago
the vaccine came out towards the
beginning of the year now people are
getting vaccinated so
the story keeps evolving the story keeps
changing fauci said you don't need to
wear a mask and you need to wear a mask
it's i think people the problem here in
america is that it got so politicized
that if you
if you're a social distancing fan and
you believe in mass that means you're a
democrat but if you're not then you're a
republican and a republican you don't
wear the mass and
it's just such a moving situation and
there's moving targets that
this is where it just comes out
consistency patrick by the way just to
go back for a second
my son jake was a really big fan of
yours and uh he
ran the numbers for me he said that home
we were looking at for 500 a little less
than 500 000
if you paid 60 000 over asking price it
would take you 25 months
to break even so that might be a bit you
might want to take you know it would
take you 20 25 months to break even if i
paid
560 for that 490 in 25 months that home
would be worth 560.
now i mean maybe you go either way on it
but if you say i'm going to be there for
10 years
that's not a bad gig and remember it
might take you two or three months to
close
so you reduce that a little bit two
months yeah yeah
you can do the math but that's how
people should be thinking by the way by
the way
how many the question becomes how many
realtors are selling the way you just
sold right now because by the way you
don't benefit from anything you don't
sell loans you don't do
you don't sell homes so it's not like we
provide the tools like this for realtors
it's a different story but you're not
selling no i'm not selling so you're not
selling a house you don't have a house
on a market you say come and look at
this 10 million
house maybe you're representing dianne
feinstein's house in lake tahoe by the
way
you're not though right so so so the
point is the point is
today's realtor imagine a realtor today
saying adam how long you going to live
in this house
10 years then don't worry about it this
500 000 house is going to be 560 in two
years you're fine buy the house make an
offer sixty thousand dollars more think
about the way
the realtor has to sell the clients
today patrick it's a different sale i
think in life
what we want to try and do is if we
think linearly right one two three four
five yeah
and we grow that way versus
exponentially what we need to do is if
you can find points of friction all over
if you remove a point of friction like
this
you will grow exponentially it's not
just in this is there's problems like
this all over
this is a big point of friction you come
up with a solution your business grows
let's talk about what happened in miami
uh the the travesty the catastrophic
event that took place where
found nine dead 152 unaccounted for
for florida condo tower collapse go to
page
four it is on what happened here it was
all over the news and obviously we're
down here so we're hearing about it
constantly search and rescue operations
continued sunday evening nearly for four
full days after champlain tower south
partially collapsed
in surf side florida nine people are
confirmed at 152 unaccounted for
as search and rescue operations
continues sunday evening
almost four days after a 12-story
condominium building collapse in florida
chaplain south towers uh tower south
partially collapsed somewhere
during the first time miami beach the
families are missing were allowed to
privately visit the
site for the first time sunday according
to miami-dade mayor
levine cava on saturday levine calva on
saturday ordered a 30-day audit of all
residential properties five stories or
higher that are 40 years or older
and fall under the county's jurisdiction
the mayor encouraged cities to do their
own building reviews as well
okay adam you had a chance to go visit
this what's it looking like there right
now
well can you pull it up so people can't
see the site of course this story i
think broke on thursday
yep and um this story literally and
figuratively
hits close to home for me surf side is
just north by the way people sent me the
video a friend from uh uh
years ago sent me the video i looked at
the video i thought it was one of those
prop hotels that's coming down you know
how they that's exactly
right like yeah it's that thing so no no
no this is not detonating a property
this is actually out of nowhere it's
just unexpected yeah
and um usa today does a good
um way of basically showing what the
building was and what it is now and
it was matt it's like a two a third of
the building just collapsed
so i'm not sure if usa the graphic that
they have click on that right there
click on that video right there three
days ago yeah there you go click on that
uh can we show this yeah we can show
this okay
no that's definitely not a shack but go
ahead keep saying and then we'll go
after yeah so people just to put it in
perspective this is just
basically a mile north of what miami
beach proper is right so this is
surfside is in basically the 80s and 90s
just north in the 90s is what's called
bell harbor we were at the ball harbor
mall a couple months ago saint regis
exactly all that my sister and my
sister's family lives right there in
bell harbor that's where i go
and stay on the weekends and see with my
family and i grew up just up the street
in north miami beach so this is
literally
um close to home and the mayor of bell
harbor which is the town basically the
next block
over is one of my closest friends gabe
groysman he's 40 years old he's got five
daughters talking about a girl dad
he's a lawyer he's an attorney he's a
pro-israel um
very vocal person like that but he's
also the mayor of bell harbor
okay he was walking around with governor
desantis and
just seeing what the hell was going on
here's a video just for the audience to
see
look at that yeah just a scary thought
to see that just
and then this tower comes down watch
this
yeah so the the problem that i have with
i mean this is a sad situation i i don't
know anybody directly that
lived there but a lot of good friends of
mine had family there like i've won
but my buddy jared he was posting
you know please please pray for these
families i text them i said well why
do you know these people he said these
are my five cousins who moved here from
puerto rico they're all dead
the problem that i have with the media
is when the story came out and i get
that there's a sensitive story
they said building collapses one person
dead do you remember that story
i do okay so one person dead now they're
out there saying nine people are dead
and 150 something our people are
unaccounted for
what the hell do you mean unaccounted
for these people aren't traveling europe
right now
not responding to their cell phone
they're dead they're full on dead
and the the the the problem that i had
is
emotionally you hear this story there's
so much in the news right now oh one
person oh thank god only one person
no every single person in that building
if it wasn't
unaccounted for three hours get it maybe
they're coming back from summer what six
hours get it
a week later no unaccounted for yes come
on man
that's maybe that might be a few that's
a scary thought by the way yeah
so what's really scary is that guy
thomas morbido in 2018 the engineer who
gave the warning
about this and nothing was done yes so
the
a crazy i don't know how often that
happens when they give it and nobody
goes and looks into it is that a common
thing
but here's the problem i have with it is
that you can you can make the excuse and
say okay
during 2020 maybe they couldn't really
do anything with co but yeah two years
before that
why was nothing done and you talked
about this earlier about uh
the majority of houses are 40 years old
uh 1980 and 1981.
now apparently you're i mean you're the
real estate expert you've just you've
taught us a lot today
important apparently there's a 40-year
recertification
of buildings this building was built 40
years ago in 1981 yeah
so something was up with this building
something you know i don't know how it
passed its code
i don't know what kind of fraud was
going on here i think number one
you know focusing on the moment focusing
on the now cleaning this up
but bigger picture like we're talking
about real estate we're talking about
south florida we're here
is they need to go at every single
building that's 35
yes and and figure this the hell out
because
you also talk about new yorkers who are
moving here in flogs we were touching on
that earlier
a lot of people are looking at saying
you know i was considering maybe buying
a condo in south florida
maybe i was moving to south florida i'm
not so sure about that now because
you know climate change is real it's
happening whether it's man-made or not i
think that's a debate but you know
there's a rising tides here
imagine living in that building right go
back to the picture imagine you're
living in the building right next door
hey come home baby
yeah yeah hey i'll see you tonight like
imagine you're the one that's standing
what are you doing if you're are you
going back let me go get my stuff
upstairs i'm not doing it you go get it
how the hell do you sleep at night like
if you've got kids
you're going to be able to sneak up if
you're not sleeping there you're not
sleeping there
what do you do with all your stuff this
is up there all your well thank god
you're all
alive number one thank god you're alive
you just got now now try reselling that
i don't that's condos try selling that
condo and adam's point about people
being a little skittish i mean you have
to look at age because this was a little
bit older number one and number two
if it's right on the water you get that
corrosive nature of it you know so maybe
it's a little bit further back a little
less to worry about but
this is definitely something that's
going to make people think twice about
well they were basically saying
that they went into the garage and they
were showing what the hell was going on
down there and there were cracks and
it's you know obviously the pool right
there
so you look at this and look we've never
seen anything like this is insane
you it starts falling from the top and
then crack
but basically what i understand here is
the bottom
implodes and then the floor above that
follows and then the floor above that
it's like a pancake effect
so visually it looks like it's falling
from the top but no the bottom is
crumbling and then each floor boom boom
boom
so imagine a floor falling on top of you
and then the floor on top of that
falling on top of you
you're not surviving that i mean
it's insane here 152.
i wonder how long it's gonna by the way
the whole thing what you're saying is
they're fraud i don't think it's fraud
there's a lot of
buildings you go to where the elevator
inspection is supposed to be done once
every 12 months and you see the
inspection some buildings haven't been
done for three or four years
it's just a lack of uh paying attention
to details right that's really all it is
you got a lot how many elevators in
america haven't been inspected on time
today
think about it a lot of them and how
many buildings like this you think they
haven't been inspected i bet there's a
lot in america that haven't been
inspected
so think about how many others are
sitting there thinking about this saying
well what about my building like
how many people went and knocked on
their property manager's door and saying
hey
when is the last time we inspected this
in the last
week every single one of those
not just in miami i tell you there's a
lot of old buildings in america today
tenants are going to say hey johnny just
out of curiosity when do we last inspect
this building
when do we last inspected it's something
to be thinking about and by the way then
a story comes out
the tweet can you pull up john mcafee's
tweet which was going viral
everywhere people are sharing it and
john mcafee
uh tweets about the building there you
go about his building
so go to images go to images and then
we'll go to usa today so there's a tweet
that comes out
that reads the following okay uh kai
click on one of those so we can see it
that's bigger
he says uh if anything ever happens to
me
please know that the 31 terabytes of
files i have are
located on hard drives in my condo
near 88th street and collins avenue just
north of miami beach now that's june 8th
2021 right i went and looked it up on
twitter
there is no tweet with him saying that
so now go to the usa today story go back
and click on that story says fact check
no evidence john mcafee ever owned unit
and partially
collapsed florida condo which who cares
whether he owned it or rented it i'm not
worried about that what i'm worried
about is did he ever tweet that out
the claim john mcfee owned the union and
partial collapse the condominium
building of florida conspiracy theorists
are attempting to connect the death of
antivirus entrepreneur john maxwell to
florida high-rise building that
partially collapsed on june 24th
mcavee founded that june tournament
execution he was 75 is the next day
condominiums in surfside florida
collapse resulting in at least four
deaths and at least 150 people missing
the two events are unrelated but social
media users are there's a
nefarious connection john mcfee owned
the unit at the building that collapsed
the address of building 87
77 collins avenue south reads a text
message so that leads to
ap doing a story on it associated press
doing a story to respond to this
if ap does a story on this which let me
see which one it is it's page of four at
the bottom
here's what ap says claim the late john
mcafee the creator john mc antivirus
software owned the unit in the condo
building
partially collapsed thursday outside
monterey was located inside that's a
claim
ap's assessment false mcafee was found
dead in his jail cell near barcelona on
wednesday didn't own the property at the
beachfront champlain
tower south condo in florida according
to the associate press review of public
records and image of the tweet in which
mcafee claims
to own such a property is fabricated at
the close of a week
that includes the prison death of an
eccentric security software pioneer in
the collapse of a 12-story
uh oceanfront condominium tower near
miami
social media users hatched false
conspiracy conspiracy theories that
bound
the two unrelated events together and
then they found out that there's a
they found out a note in his pocket and
his jail cell yeah
that read what did it read it said the
uh uh uh there was a note in it you know
which one i'm talking about
where you know act and yeah
so apparently they found another and his
wife said there's no way in the world my
husband would commit suicide his last
words were
i love you babe i'll talk to you later
so she's like there's no way this
happens
so pat there's that word again that
we're starting to touch on a little bit
more and more and more conspiracy
theories
yeah we're starting to touch on this a
little bit more and something tells me
with this guy mcafee
eccentric dude and all this stuff you
interviewed the guy i mean we spent
an hour talking about this guy let's not
watch the interview the interview in the
last
few days has taken off it's been
everywhere everyone's messaging us
what was your thoughts about meeting
this guy look if the tweet
is not up there you know june of 08 june
of
june 8th of this year easily you can
make a fake tweet and put it out there
right
now some people are saying well what if
somebody on twitter went and deleted it
i don't know about that if it did
there'd be plenty of people with
screenshots who had it because to say
you know then there's some people that
are saying that 31 terabytes you should
have seen what's in it because if that
reveals itself
then kai said something very interesting
yesterday saying look
if if mcafee is who i think it is and
there's really a lot of credibility
behind what was in that 31 terabytes
do you really think he would only have
one copy of it in one place no no one
the way he would be he'd probably have
five ten of them
and would have him tell everybody where
it is
i don't know if he would tell everybody
where it is the point is he had some
information that people didn't want to
have
seen what that is in there some of us
will know some of us will never know
some of us are never going to know what
was in hillary clinton's clinton's
emails that was
you know some of us are not going to
know what was in biden's laptop because
he had the fbi doesn't want to
investigate it
but there's definitely a little bit of
thought of what was really in that 31
terabytes that this guy had i'd be so
curious to know what was in it and i'm
willing to bet there are millions of
others
that want to know was it just a picture
it's a bunch of uh
you know random crazy files that he had
or is there anything there
that the world would want to know about
and if it's yes
maybe there is somebody who's a hacker
trying to really figure out what was in
there there's plenty of professional
hackers today that could find a lot of
different things
maybe someone's working on something
right now let me tell you this isn't the
end of the john mcafee conspiracy
theories that are going to run rampant i
don't think there's going to be a lot
more
uh i heard this i saw this but just to
be clear
uh there's no uh credibility to this
story no no no no
actually um my son dan just told him
snopes he looked up snopes as well yeah
i don't even look at snopes because
snopes to me also has made a lot of
mistakes themselves of saying it's false
but it was
true if ap is coming out and saying
something about it
ap is typically you know they got not
not that i mean look we're a customer of
them we like doing business with ap
but if ap saying something about it ap
is not even saying
the only thing that ap said is the fact
that he didn't own it so they want to
look at the record but they're not
saying
that that's a false claim they're just
saying conspiracy theories so
who knows what's going to come out i can
tell you like you said next week two
week three weeks i'm sure there's gonna
be more stuff that's gonna come out
about this year uh fyi we have some of
the logos kai if you want to pull it up
i just want to show the logos we still
haven't finalized any one of them
a couple of them i like i'm curious to
know your thoughts we put numbers right
next to them so if you take a look at
these logos whichever one you like we
have to pick a local
for the podcast here kai can you pull
that up so we can show it to the
audience
and fyi if you are a graphic designer
and you see any designs you want to put
for pbd podcast this is what we
currently have right now
there's numbers next to it take a look
see which one you like
put a number next to it we're definitely
uh
taking as many feedback as possible but
these are some of the ones that people
have sent us here for the podcast pvp
podcast the top right one number 10.
it's kind of florida number nine is kind
of cool with the line number seven is
the
different look number six is the lion
again 25 is the mic
uh if there's any of these you like put
the number below we're going to go back
and look at them
and we're going to narrow it down and
again if you got if you're somebody
that's watching this
and you know graphic designers we're
going to give the winner 500.
for whoever comes out with the podcast
local that we end up using
submit it to us kai what's the email to
send it to it's actually send it on
twitter and hashtag pbd podcast
because it's the easiest way to track
them if you got a logo is there any one
or two that kind of stands out
i like seven seven colors interesting
yeah that's kind of interesting old
school
20 is kind of unique the way 20 is doing
it is that my
20 caught my eye because that's your
face in the mic is that what it is i
just noticed it right now first time
whoever did 20 20 is kind of obviously
11 they're
doing the same identical thing as uh uh
our buddy rogan did
which that's his image but uh 20 is kind
of cool yeah i mean
look again if you got any other send it
our way we're paying attention to it and
thank you to everyone who's actually
been submitting these we're reviewing
them
we appreciate it 100 and one of you guys
is gonna get 500 bucks
last question for you if you would like
to see our friend barry the real estate
expert if you learned a lot today and
you would like to see him
have a show with us potentially like
danny of the martina booth
like adam like general spalding like tom
ellsworth
like some of the folks that we have if
you'd like to see him have a show on
valuetainment economics
reacting to current events that taking
place with real estate rates any of that
click the thumbs up subscribe to the
channel and
let us know why we're watching all the
commentary because we're having
conversations right about potentially
doing that when we do that we'll launch
it to everybody you'll be the first to
know it
when that comes about having said that
barry thank you so much for coming out
thank you very much
we got his book right here kai let's put
the link to his book below so if people
want to order this book they can do that
as well
money in the streets with that being
said once again take care everybody have
a great week we'll do this again
thursday we have a special guest i
believe this thursday
this thursday can i tell you who but i
think you're going to like it we have a
potential
california person that's running for
governor
with us here this thursday do not miss
this thursday's podcast
it will be fired take care everybody bye
bye bye
you